oh yeah I found it I found the treasure
I feel like Sir Francis Drake I have
found that which is worse than vacation
[Music]
this movie whatever masterminds yes it's
got named it after a cool game so
masterminds I guess is based on a true
story
so I hear if so it's a tragedy because
the story is interesting enough to
warrant a good movie for it but we have
this we just got to deal with this [ __ ]
mastermind stars Zach Galifianakis he
works for Wells Fargo Loomis Fargo does
one of those armored truck companies so
Owen Wilson gets together with Kristin
Wiggs character used to work with Zach
Galifianakis this character Zach
Galifianakis this character has a crush
on Kristin Wiggs characters - Owen
Wilson uses that to basically be like
hey Gallivan haggis steal from the
armored truck company you work for and
let's make some money didn't get screwed
through the whole deal and now we have a
wreck just an absolute mess one of those
movies that probably should have been
locked in an armored car and then
dropped at the bottom of an ocean never
to be found again that ever was pretty
shaky but that's that's what happens
when I watch garbage series nothing in
this movie works like zero there's
nothing in this movie I like all the
characters sucked all like there's
stupid - an unbearably dirty degree and
that's just individually none of them
worked together
nobody had chemistry in this movie
everybody was awkward Galifianakis we
know is going to be awkward and we know
he's going to be an idiot but usually
he's a lovable idiot usually but he
makes us laugh right sometimes no or was
that just in the first hangover movie
anyhow now we're hearing it rather be at
the dentist
Kate McKinnon's in the movie Kate
McKinnon is if you liked the 2016
Ghostbusters movie she's the reason why
she was painful to watch - she was
painfully awkward I get what she was
trying to go for she's supposed to be a
weirdo with a crazy eye but there was a
story of a dude who tried to glide off
of the Eiffel Tower it didn't work he
fell to his death you don't get points
for trying sometimes people just fail
don't feel bad kate mckinnon so did
everybody else the things that made me
laugh in the movie were this situational
circumstances you know like Zach
Galifianakis this car is a piece of [ __ ]
and the door is this big piece of
plywood with a hinge on it that just
made me laugh
laughs is a strong word I just chuckled
at the prospect of it now everything
else man no don't know one of those
movies you walk out of and you just know
you're gonna [ __ ] on it it's all about
house like how do I want to murder this
thing do I just knife it do I shoot it
do I strap a piece of dynamite to it do
I drop it out of an airplane riding a
nuclear warhead but in the end I have a
video so I just have to [ __ ] on it
verbally
that's my weapon guys in the end nothing
about this movie appealed to me
whatsoever there's some good comedic
talent in here but there was some great
talent movie 43 also just say it was
painful it was awkward it was boring it
was a shame because the prospect of the
story is interesting you want to see
that story told in a way that just is
better doesn't even have to be a comedy
I'm interested in the story one of the
worst of the year folks I'm going to say
masterminds is in fact [ __ ]
actually one thing made me laugh it was
actually a smart move it was a smart
tactic because in the end credits
there's the behind that you know the
blooper reel that they show while
credits are going sometimes outtakes and
bloopers are always fun to watch you're
watching the actors have a good time and
it is solid proof that even actors have
a good time or can have a good time when
they're making a [ __ ] sandwich because
they're not the ones who have to eat it
you do I'm glad they can have a good
time but I see through the tactic well
you're sitting there in pain as the
movie is now ending and you feel like
you've just gotten your taint licked by
Johnny Mick cactus tongue you're left on
a salted low and then the end credits
happened with a blooper reel and you're
like I'm actually chuckling at that I'm
chuckling at the actors the people
having a good time that's actually a
good feel-good thing you leave on enough
that's not quite as low as you were a
second ago but now doesn't fool me that
has actually nothing to do with the
movie all right guys so masterminds
don't watch it I'm not gonna ask if
you've seen it what did you think about
it because that that would imply that
you now have to go to watch it to answer
the question I'm gonna ask you now I'm
going to do that too but I will ask what
is the worst comedy of the year for you
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]